all right welcome back everyone to my
final round recap from mule as you can
maybe tell I'm in a slightly different
location than my previous Recaps after
this game I I was just exhausted it was
a crazy crazy fight it was a long
tournament too and um I've taken a few
days to rest and recover but um yeah
this game was nothing short of just a
roller coaster and if you watch my
previous Recaps you'll maybe know that
my previous few games were very very
clean like according to stockfish I
played maybe two or three perfect games
in a row at least according to like the
quick leeches analysis with stockfish
but this game had a lot of swings in
both directions
and it started with an English opening I
chose to play C4
and I did a little bit of preparation
for my opponent beforehand I saw he
plays E6 and I decided to play an
opening that I played in my uh previous
round game I believe it was against
Jonathan Monte Verde I think this was
round seven uh if I just switched this
game you can see we got the same
position from a slightly different move
order and this opening repertoire was
inspired by Hikaru because it's a line
that Hikaru plays a lot in online and
Blitz and bullets and it's a way to kind
of stay flexible as whites there's many
times where I'll play D4 but there's
also times where I'll delay D4 and React
to what black is doing and my opponent
started taking time pretty early in the
game uh it took some time before playing
Pawn to B6 I play Pawn B3 Bishop B7
should be two and then he plays Pawn to
Asics and I actually took my first think
of the game in this position because I
was trying to decide whether to go for
or the more traditional setup with D4
and Bishop D3 or to play something a
little bit more creative and offbeat and
ultimately I choose to play the move
Pawn to G3
and I'm pretty sure in my previous recap
against Jonathan Monteverde I'd
mentioned the fact that I was
considering playing a very similar move
early on in the game and it's an
interesting approach for white because
it at first it feels weird to put the
pawns on E3 and G3 but the idea is to
Simply fiend color the bishop Castle
have a very safe King side and still
later go for a setup with D4 and just be
ultra solid with a double fincato and
good central control so I played this
move and my opponent took some time to
react and he played Pawn to C5
I took on G5 and takes back I played
Bishop to G2 he plays Bishop D6 I castle
castle and then I go for Pawn to D4 and
what I'm basically trying to achieve is
a preferable Pawn structure for whites I
would really like it if we trade C Pawn
for d-pawn for example if black takes
here I take back with knights this is
just a dream position for whites given
that I'm blockading this isolate Queen's
pawn and the D5 Pawn is just a long-term
weakness for black and White's pieces
are just really really nicely placed in
this position now I can't force The
Exchange right away and my opponent
played Rook to E8
and around this moment I actually want
to share uh an interesting story there's
actually a slightly embarrassing story
on my parts uh coming into this game I
had a hard time preparing for my
opponents because I couldn't find too
many of his games in the database
and I decided to play this uh this
opening the morning of the game and
shortly before the game starting I
realized he plays this opening as white
but it was only once we got out of the
opening and into the middle game I had a
sudden flashback that I played this
opponent a few days earlier in the bill
Blitz tournament and I recorded that
game it's on video and I'll probably
like overlay the video here so you guys
can see but we played a game where he
was white and he played pretty much his
exact same opening as I'm playing in
this game and I'll just toggle here to
show but this is a position we had a few
days prior I was playing the black
pieces and the start to the game was
almost identical okay he played Rook C1
instead of G3 but then he still later
played uh some interesting setup and we
got a very similar structure so so I was
a little bit surprised with myself
during the game that I didn't remember
that I played the same person like even
after sitting down and playing the first
few opening moves I was just blind to
the fact that we we played a few days uh
prior and I think the cause of this was
the fact that I just played so much
chess over the course of um about 10
days between the classical chess I
played the blitz side events before that
I played the rapid Side Event and the
960 side events so it was just a lot to
take in and I had some small Amnesia
remembering that uh I had this same
opening and same opponent but different
colors
so I guess I was fortunate to still get
like a very fine position especially
given that my opponent has experience
from the white side of this position
and going forward from here things went
pretty smoothly I play Rook C1 he
completes development and then I found a
really nice idea here to play the move
Knights to H4 I guess this is a novelty
this position has happened once before
between doganov and korchmar I was
unaware of that during the game but the
idea of Knight H4 is to exert more
pressure against the D5 pawn and what
I'm threatening here is to take on C5
and then take on D5 because then I would
have three attackers given the queen
would then be Unleashed and I didn't
want to take immediately on C5 if we
just look at the difference of this line
if I play Knight H4 here black would
have Knight B6 with the B6 Square
cleared for the Knight and the d-pawn
would be supported now this would be
playable this is a hanging Pawn
structure two pawns next to each other
with no pawns on the adjacent files I
think this is still Pleasant
positionally for white to play
but compare this to the game after
Knight H4 there's this very big threat
of taking and it's not so clear how
black
deals with the threat and avoids getting
lice at Queen's pawn and what ended up
happening he took on D4 I take back with
queen and I achieve my dream position of
playing against Black's isolate Queen's
Pawn now it is true that the queen isn't
ideal on D4 and it does get kicked he
plays Bishop to E5 I move back to D3 my
queen gets kicked again with Knight C5 I
go back to B1 so couple
um passive retreating moves but long
term I'm still feeling very good because
this Pawn has a hard time trading itself
off like he can't really push right away
because I think the trades are favorable
for whites I would take back and then
there's lines where if takes takes takes
there's Rook D1 and some nasty pin on
the D file so the pawn is staying on D5
uh in the game he plays Knight fe4 I
play Knight F3 uh this is a useful move
my Knight has served its purpose on H4
getting out the way of the bishop now
comes back even though it's blocking the
bishop I am guarding the D2 Square so
not getting Forks also wanting to take
on E5 and get the bishop pair so he
Retreats and I play Rook F to D1 so I'm
basically just trying to achieve the
ideal setup of my pieces and pretty much
everything is happy here and even though
the queen looks maybe a little bit weird
on B1 it still has some influence in the
center also has ideas of Queen A1 uh
potentially creating the battery against
the G7 Pawn
so going forward from here uh we trade
Knights takes takes he plays Knight E4 I
drop back he plays Queen E7 I play
Knight to D4 so my double fiend cattle
is shining a bit more in this position
and now I'm having ideas of knife to F5
with the triple Fork hitting the bishop
Queen and G7 Pawn
and yeah nylon F5 combined with a bishop
on B2 is just a very dangerous
combination for black to deal with
so he plays Queen G5 I improved my queen
plays rook ac-8 and next several moves
it's a little bit of dancing around we
do trade Rooks I play Knight H4 again
threatening knife F5
um I might have to credit Ben Feingold
for coining that phrase uh thank you Ben
if you're watching knife F5 you call
that a knife unfortunately my opponent
actually put up a lot of resistance here
I was not able to easily win material
after Bishop f8 he's just holding his
ground and I go for Knight F5 he plays
Queen E6 and my Knight has done like
kind of a full tour I played a lot of
Night Moves In this game but it returns
to D4 and after Queen at six there is a
little bit of counter play against the
pawn on F2 and at this point I was
having flashbacks to my previous round
game against suvir Molly I just want to
show a moment in this game this is also
an iqp position and this game I had big
issues with my F2 Pawn
so going back to the round 10 game I was
very careful not to let F2 Pawn become a
bigger problem than it needs to be
and I simply defend it with Rook F1 he
plays Pawn to B5 and in this position I
found a nice idea to play Bishop H3 and
the point of this move is simply to
attack the rook and make my opponent
choose where he wants to put the Rook
now what he ended up playing was Rook E8
which is a very big concession because
he is no longer fighting for the only
open file on the board
I was happily able to play Queen C2 and
take over the file with my queen and
yeah the C8 square is just off limits
for The Rook I was thinking that if he
plays Rook to C7 here I would have a
tactic Knight takes B5 which I'm pretty
sure is just crushing for whites hitting
queen and the rook and it takes takes
then lights is just winning material
maybe what he should have done in the
game is play Rook C5
uh even though it looks a little bit
awkward it seems like maybe The Rook can
be exploited here there's Bishop A3
ideas it's not entirely clear how whites
can punish black because Bishop A3 runs
into Rook C3
B4 would run into Rook C4 and the move
that I really want to play is 96 hitting
the queen hitting the Rook Knight's
defended by the bishop but this wouldn't
quite work because Queen Jakes B2 and
when I take the Rook he takes back and
black would win two minor pieces for The
Rook
but none of this happened because he
played rookie Eights and then the next
few moves it felt just very good to make
continual improvements starting with
Queen C2 and after Queen H6 I played
Bishop to D7 and I was really feeling
the initiative and momentum on my side
with this move I'm hitting the Rook
forcing it to move somewhere and after
Rook A8 I go in with a queen uh Queen to
C7 now I should note that he probably
should have played Rook B8 with idea
that if I play Queen C7 he would then
have Bishop D6 and the bishop is
defended by the queen which defends a
rook which defends a bishop by Queen's
attacks and there's not a clear way for
me to actually win anything in this
position
but the difference is after Rook A8
Queen C7 his Bishop on B7 is not
defended he has no time for Bishop D6 so
he had to play pretty ugly defensive
move Knight to C5 which covers the
bishop but now it seems like Block's
position is very very delicate and on
top of that I just have a huge time
Advantage I have 28 minutes and some
change and he is already below 90
seconds and we're on move 32 and there's
eight more moves to make until we get
extra time so I felt like I should just
be winning in the next few moves and I
played the move Knights to F5 after
about three minutes of thinking now
Knight F5 it's a strong move but I
really should have taken my time because
it turns out that I had a much simpler
way to convert the position I could have
simply played the move on to B4 I have
no idea is just to remove the knight
from defending the bishop on B7 if he
plays Knight D3 I take and hit the rook
and he has no time really to take my
Bishop on B2
I think the reason why I didn't go with
B4 in the game was I wasn't sure about
Bishop to D6 but really I should have
just done the concrete calculation
because I can simply play Queen B6 here
and black has the same issue of the
Knight and Bishop both pressured and uh
the lines to acknowledge here for white
is after it takes takes I'm hitting the
Rook hitting the knights and after Rook
d8 I'd have the final kind of knockout
blow Knight C6 exploiting the rook and
um yeah there's no way for black to not
lose material in this position so this
would have been a very manageable line
to calculate
but I saw it on F5 it looked really
powerful and I played it so in this
position I was still feeling really good
hitting the queen pressuring G7 black is
still very much on the back foot on just
all areas of the board but he kept
fighting he plays Queen to G5 and in
this position okay I'm hiding notation
because I don't want to spoil too much
but here I played what I thought was
just an absolutely brilliant move
and I'll go ahead and show the move that
I played Bishop takes G7 and it seemed
like that this move would certainly be
the straw that breaks the camel's back
uh the camel being a Black's position
and it just seems like everything is
falling apart for black given that the
bishop is tied down to the thing the
knights Knights tied down to defending
the bishop which then could lead to
issues with the Rook on eights I just
thought that there's no way black is
going to survive from here
now before I show what happens in the
game I want to make a note here that
Bishop takes V7 was a big mistake and I
only had one completely winning move in
the position
so for those watching if you want to
treat this as an exercise this is white
to move and find the only completely
winning move
now I will say that B4 crossed my mind
but this is not a winning move because
black has an idea Queen d8 and somehow
this holds everything if takes takes we
could trade but White's not winning
material
so
I saw the idea of Queen d8 and that's
the reason why I wanted to take on G7
but the winning move for white is to
play Rook to see one and it's the same
principle of removing the guard of the
bishop on B7 and now if Queen
to d8 I can simply take the knights and
I defend my queen so if takes takes
lights up a piece and if takes that I
take here and I have two minor pieces
for Rook also probably winning the D5
Pawn so this is just crushing for white
not to mention the G7 Pawn is also
attacked
so
I should have found Rook C1 it would
have just led to very very good things
probably an easy conversion
but uh I played Bishop takes G7
and the problem with this move
is black has
a very precise way
to respond and my opponent found it with
very little time so kudos to my opponent
for finding Knight takes D7 I think I
was aware of this move when I was
calculating Bishop takes G7 but I wasn't
fully aware of the lines that come after
uh now I do want to note that one reason
I played this move was if Queen d8 which
seems to also maybe hold for black
there's a very powerful response Queen
E5 completely abandoning the bishop on
D7 and threatening mate in one with
Knight H6 so either thing takes Knight
h6's mate of course if takes takes this
is also made so I was excited about this
line but after he takes on D7
I began to think I realized the position
is really not so simple it seems like
there should be multiple ways for white
to get an edge here but the problem
arises if I take the Knight and I think
this was my original plan uh there's a
very strong move for black Bishop C8
of course if he takes on G7 I take the
bishop and life is good but after Bishop
C8 I couldn't find an edge for whites if
I play Queen E8 going for this there is
Bishop takes F5 defending the bishop
through x-ray vision I have no time to
mail on f8s and after it takes takes I
think it's black who can only play for a
win here the two Bishops are very strong
in the end game and my light squares are
very weak so I rejected Queen D7 because
of Bishop C8 and I also rejected Queen
takes B7 because of the move Queen takes
F5 and I really wanted to go into this
line but after Queen takes eight King
takes G7 lock again gets two minor
pieces for a rook and I'm left with
pieces that are not so well coordinated
even if I win a pawn here I was trying
to assess this line it just looks very
messy especially from a distance but
looking at it now it seems like black is
in very good shape after Knight E5 ideas
of Knight F3 and getting some mating
mats against my king
so going back after he took on D7 I took
a lot of time here I think I took about
13 minutes to play the move Bishop takes
f8
and when I played this move I was still
feeling like I have good chances to win
the game first of all I shouldn't
mention his time situation is very very
low uh he played Knight takes E7 with
two seconds on the clock because there
was a 30 second grip so he had 32
seconds after playing this move
and after takes we are on move 35 so he
still has five more moves to make until
getting extra time basically only has 30
seconds on average to make the rest of
his uh his five moves and my deal with
Bishop takes f8 is after he takes on F5
I play the move Bishop H6 and I've
sacrificed a piece I'm officially down a
minor piece but my idea is I'm hitting
the bishop on B7 and after he defends it
with Rook B8 and this happened in the
game I played the move Rook C1 I blitzed
out this move and the idea now is to
sacrifice my queen I want to take on B7
and say oh no my queen and if Lock's not
careful and plays some careless move
and takes the queen then it's mating
Knight f8 Rook takes f8 is checkmates
and there's actually multiple lines
where the queen can be sacked like if he
plays Rook C8 thinking he's skewering I
just take the rook and this is again
worse mates the King has just mated on
the back rank
so he was very aware of the danger
and with just 43 seconds left on the
clock he found the only move
to not lose in this position is Pawn F6
which gives the king some loot even
though it looks weakening it's
completely necessary for black to stop
the threats of Queen dxb7
now I had seen this position from back
when I played Bishop takes f8 and I had
looked further and I very quickly played
the move Queen to D6 I'm trying to put
my opponent under the most amount of
pressure as possible
I should note he played the move F6 with
one second on his clock so he was
flirting with flagging but uh didn't
quite run out of time and when I played
this move I thought that I still have a
really dangerous attack because now my
threat is Rook to C7
and he responded with the move Pawn to
D4 which turned out to be a reasonable
move but incredibly there is a winning
move for black in this position what he
should have done and this this probably
just would have required many more
minutes for him to think but the the
engine move for lack is Rook T8
and the idea of this move is he's
preventing Queen E7 so I don't have a
quick way to threaten Checkmate and
during the game I thought if he plays
this move I would just go in with Rook
C7 and still have a ton of pressure it
looks like light's doing very well here
but it turns out black has another
incredible resource is to play the move
Pawn to D4
and
if we went into this black is just
completely winning because he's
threatening Checkmate in one he's
unleashed the bishop I no longer have
the G2 Square accessible for my king and
if I take the bishop here he can check
King G2 Queen E4 and then I'm just
losing my rook and yeah I'm down a full
Rook here I have no no way to exploit
the black king and this would just be
completely completely winning so I'm
very fortunate that my opponents did not
find rookies followed by D4 he played D4
a bit too soon and we're still before
move 40 uh we're on move 38. and I play
the move Queen E7 threatening checkmates
he responds with Queen G6 defending G7
also attacked my bishop and after takes
takes
we're finally on move 40 so that means
we both get an additional 50 minutes and
we've switched now from what felt like a
bullet game back to a classical game and
the dust has settled a little bit and
we're now in a position where it's still
unclear what's going on I'm still down
the piece black has this very deadly
looking Bishop on B7 but I have counter
play I have ideas of Rook C7 and the
king is quite open Black's Rook is very
passive
so once we got to this position I wasn't
sure if I could be winning maybe it's a
draw maybe I'm losing like if the queen
gets to G2 it's just game over so going
forward from here we're gonna see how
the position plays out I started with
Rook C7 which is really the most logical
move threatening ideas of Queen F7 also
ideas of taking the bishop and he saves
his Bishop with Bishop to F3 and for a
moment here I thought I'm just very
close to losing because if I play Queen
F7
he simply plays King h8
and there's no clear way for white to
get to the king he's controlling all the
key squares around the king with his
pieces and then I have to worry about
this Pawn tension like he's threatening
to take so yeah there is a moment where
I thought I might just be losing from
this position but I pretty quickly
realized that I have a bailout and after
a bit of thought I played the move Queen
to E6 and after King h8 the reason for
putting the queen on E6 and not F7 is in
this position I have Brook C8 and I
force a rook trade and after takes takes
G7 it was around here that I offered him
a draw because I was very very certain
that I just have Perpetual check now he
declined the draw and after I play Queen
D7 there was a bit of dancing he was
maybe thinking about going up with the
King but then he ultimately moved back
to G7 I should note if he moves up with
a king
at the very least I have H4
and maybe it's close to winning like
King G4 Queen year
F5 loses a queen and if this this yeah
I'd be winning in this position Queen G5
is the only legal move
so
yeah King G5 was too risky you moved
back after check here check here check
uh he found the only other way to try to
avoid the Perpetual with King to E8 and
I really thought he was gonna just take
a draw any moment but he ran
to the queen side
and then I had to think like what's the
best way to keep the king kind of locked
in on the edge because there's a bunch
of tracks with Queen E6 there's Queen
takes A6 but if I take on A6 he can
bring the bishop back and maybe try and
shelter the king
so I took my time and I concluded that
I'm okay taking the A6 Pawn after Bishop
to B7 I still give checks
and we got to this position after Queen
C5 and now it's a case where if he moves
to the D file I'm happy to take another
Pawn with check I thought maybe there's
cases where he might over push and maybe
I can still have winning chances but
after King B8 I figured that it's not
worth taking the risk of taking the pawn
and giving him a move so I keep checking
and
now we finally did agree to the draw we
I think repeated at least three times
and the game ended peacefully after what
was a very big roller coaster I'm a
little bit scared to
click this uh my Naval engine analysis
I'm a little bit scared to click this
button but
I guess I'll do so and we'll see what uh
what stockfish thinks yeah here we can
see
definitely not a perfect game I was
completely winning in this moment after
Queen C7 I really should have found B4
and I also probably should have found
Rook C1 when I had the chance this still
would have been very winning for whites
but then I was fortunate after I took on
f8 I was in a losing position and all it
would have taken was for my opponent to
find one accurate move rookie Yates
although it wasn't the easiest move to
find
so I think a draw is
a somewhat Fair results it could have
gone either way but it is nice to finish
the tournament with a story to tell in
this game and I really hope people
enjoyed all my games as tournaments it
was a thrill to play it's my first time
playing in Buell and uh just the
conditions were very nice I'd want to
give a huge thank you to the organizers
of this tournament for making it just an
amazing experience
I I don't know how to end this video but
I think what I'll do is I'll share some
tennis Clips because throughout the
tournaments I found some time to play
some tennis and I actually do have a big
announcement which I don't think I've
mentioned on YouTube yet but in a few
days from now it will be the weekend of
August 4th I'm actually competing in a
chess and Tennis hybrid tournament it's
called The Chess tennis world
championship it'll be in bad and bad in
Germany and I have my Rockets with me
I'm probably gonna buy some new tennis
shoes but I'm looking forward to it it
has kind of a similar format to chess
boxing but less punching people in the
face and there's gonna be a lot of
strong chess players there some strong
tennis players I know fellow streamer
and content creator Katie learns is
going to be there he actually told me
about the events so should be super fun
so I'll end this video with some
highlights from my tennis from the last
week so hope you guys enjoy and stay
tuned for some maybe different type of
content coming up and I'll see you guys
soon
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]